Welcome back.
We were in the midst of figuring
out the Laplace
transform of sine of at when
I was running out of time.
This was the definition
of the Laplace
transform of sine of at.
I said that also equals y.
This is going to be useful for
us, since we're going to be
doing integration
by parts twice.
So I did integration by parts
once, then I did integration
by parts twice.
I said, you know, don't worry
about the boundaries of the
integral right now.
Let's just worry about the
indefinite integral.
And then after we solve for y--
let's just say y is the
indefinite version of this--
then we can evaluate the
boundaries.
And we got to this point, and we
made the realization, after
doing two integration by parts
and being very careful not to
hopefully make any careless
mistakes, we realized, wow,
this is our original y.
If I put the boundaries here,
that's the same thing as the
Laplace transform of
sine of at, right?
That's our original y.
So now-- and I'll switch colors
just avoid monotony--
this is equal to, actually,
let me just-- this is y.
Right?
That was our original
definition.
So let's add a squared over
sine squared y to
both sides of this.
So this is equal to y plus--
I'm just adding this whole
term to both sides of this
equation-- plus a squared over
s squared y is equal to-- so
this term is now gone, so it's
equal to this stuff.
And let's see if we
can simplify this.
So let's factor out an e to the
minus st. Actually, let's
factor out a negative e to the
minus st. So it's minus e to
the minus st, times sine of--
well, let me just write 1 over
s, sine of at, minus 1 over
s squared, cosine of at.
I really hope I haven't made
any careless mistakes.
And so this, we can add
the coefficient.
So we get 1 plus a squared,
over s squared, times y.
But that's the same thing as s
squared over s squared, plus a
squared over s squared.
So it's s squared plus a
squared, over s squared, y is
equal to minus e to the minus
st, times this whole thing,
sine of at, minus 1 over s
squared, cosine of at.
And now, this right here, since
we're doing everything
with respect to dt, this is
just a constant, right?
So we can say a constant
times the
antiderivative is equal to this.
This is as good a time as any
to evaluate the boundaries.
Right?
If this had a t here, I would
have to somehow get them back
on the other side.
Because the t's are involved in
evaluating the boundaries,
since we're doing our definite
integral or improper integral.
So let's evaluate the
boundaries now.
And we could've kept
them along with us
the whole time, right?
And just factored out this
term right here.
But anyway.
So let's evaluate this
from 0 to infinity.
And this should simplify
things.
So the right-hand side of this
equation, when I evaluate it
at infinity, what is e to
the minus infinity?
Well, that is 0.
We've established that
multiple times.
And now it approaches 0 from
the negative side, but it's
still going to be 0,
or it approaches 0.
What's sine of infinity?
Well, sine just keeps
oscillating, between negative
1 and plus 1, and
so does cosine.
Right?
So this is bounded.
So this thing is going
to overpower these.
And if you're curious,
you can graph it.
This kind of forms an envelope
around these oscillations.
So the limit, as this approaches
infinity, is going
to be equal to 0.
And that makes sense, right?
These are bounded between
0 and negative 1.
And this approaches
0 very quickly.
So it's 0 times something
bounded between 1
and negative 1.
Another way to view it is the
largest value this could equal
is 1 times whatever
coefficient's on it, and then
this is going to 0.
So it's like 0 times 1.
Anyway, I don't want to focus
too much on that.
You can play around with
that if you like.
Minus this whole thing
evaluated at 0.
So what's e to the minus 0?
Well, e to the minus 0 is 1.
Right?
That's e to the 0.
We have a minus 1, so it becomes
plus 1 times-- now,
sine of 0 is 0.
Minus 1 over s squared,
cosine of 0.
Let's see.
Cosine of 0 is 1, so we have
minus 1 over s squared, minus
1 over s squared, times 1.
So that is equal to minus
1 over s squared.
And I think I made a mistake,
because I shouldn't be having
a negative number here.
So let's backtrack.
Maybe this isn't a
negative number?
Let's see, infinity, right?
This whole thing is 0.
When when you put 0 here,
this becomes a minus 1.
Yeah.
So either this is a plus
or this is a plus.
Let's see where I
made my mistake.
e to the minus st-- oh, I
see where my mistake is.
Right up here.
Where I factored out a minus
e to the minus st, right?
Fair enough.
So that makes this 1
over s, sine of at.
But if I factor out a minus e to
the minus st, this becomes
a plus, right?
It was a minus here, but I'm
factoring out of a minus e to
the minus st.
So that's a plus.
This is a plus.
Boy, I'm glad that was not
too difficult to find.
So then this becomes a plus.
And then this becomes a plus.
Thank God.
It would have been sad if I
wasted two videos and ended up
with a careless, negative
number.
Anyway.
So now we have s squared plus
a squared, over s squared,
times y is equal to this.
Multiply both sides times
s squared over-- s
squared plus a squared.
Divide both sides by this, and
we get y is equal to 1 over s
squared-- And actually, let me
make sure that that is right.
It's 1 over s squared.
y is equal to 1 over s squared,
times s squared, over
s squared plus a squared.
And then these cancel out.
And let me make sure
that I haven't made
another careless mistake.
Because I have a
feeling I have. Yep.
There.
I see the careless mistake.
And it was all in this term.
And I hope you don't mind my
careless mistakes, but I want
you to see that I'm doing these
things in real time and
I am human, in case you haven't
realized already.
Anyway, so I made the same
careless mistake.
So I factor out an e to the
minus st here, so it's plus.
But it was a over s squared.
So this is an a.
That's an a.
And so this is an a.
Right?
This was an a.
And this is the correct
answer.
a over s squared
plus a squared.
So I hope those careless
mistakes didn't
throw you off too much.
These things happen when you do
integration by parts twice
with a bunch of variables.
But anyway, now we are ready
to add a significant entry
into our table of Laplace
transforms. And that is that
the Laplace transform-- I had
an extra curl, there.
That was unecessary.
Let me do it again.
The Laplace transform of sine
of at is equal to a over s
squared, plus a squared.
And that's a significant
entry.
And maybe a good exercise for
you, just to see how fun it is
to do these integration by parts
problems twice, is to
figure out the Laplace transform
of cosine of at.
And I'll give you a hint.
It's s over s squared over
s squared plus a squared.
And it's nice that there's
that symmetry there.
Anyway, I'm almost
at my time limit.
And I'm very tired working
on this video.
So I'll leave it there and I'll
see you in the next one.